this
is star talk
uh all right here's another question
from susan minob
uh
people often complain about the nasa
budget and claim the pro that private
industry should take over some of the
work that nasa does but they don't do it
already because the of government but
they don't they do it already because of
government contracts what percent of the
nasa budget goes to private sector
contractors that that's the question
i don't know but it's got to be enormous
whenever you buy hardware you're buying
it from companies like boeing yeah
united launch alliance what have you
yeah nasa buys stuff from a lot of
companies right but in the business
contractors to work from it's only have
a certain number of people working in
the nasa workforce how much stuff is
built there i decided
let's say you have a mars rover
hypothetically it's machined the metal
is cut at the jet propulsion lab in
pasadena some of it the mirrors are
coated somewhere else the lenses are
ground somewhere else and these are all
done by companies but the fundamental
idea if i can read into this question
there's no right now there's no business
model that takes people to mars
there's no business model to find out
whether the core of jupiter has hydrogen
that acts like a metal there's just no
reason for a private company to do that
at this time even though i'm very
curious well yes
that don't put bread on the table eugene
well you don't know that because you
might find something about the hydrogen
metal that would affect the way we make
uh semiconductors or micro circuits or
something yeah with that said
these things are all built by
contractors and the then the crossover
right now is the guys the people who
want to mine asteroids
and at first it sounds sexy and fabulous
and literally a shiny object to go to an
asteroid and get platinum yeah but
apparently
the big thing they want to get on
asteroids is water
so you take water and then it's fuel for
your spaceship to keep going so you you
have solar panels
on your spaceship your thing your
spacecraft
you get out there into the asteroid you
electrolyze water make it hydrogen and
oxygen
somehow put it in a tank how hard could
it be in outer space
millions of kilometers from here yeah
and then you would have fuel to go on to
some other exotic destination maybe to
your platinum-bearing asteroid and you
drag that back to the earth and get rich
that's a pretty good plan all right